foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
elucidating the composition of crispr
cast 12 F1 complexes using mass
photometry I am Julie abbing of lab
roots and I will be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by refine to learn more
visit refine.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we as time as we have time
for at the end of the presentation you
may also submit to any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation I'd like to
now welcome our speaker salgar Henkel
heineke PhD student at the University of
Leipzig celgar you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for joining this webinar today
I am a Sega Heineken I'm at the Dubai
Peter Dubai Institute force of
metaphysics at the University of Leipzig
in the group of brothers titles and I
will talk today about elucidating the
composition of crispr customer with one
complexes with uh or by using Mass
photometry
so crispacas
effective complexes so what are they
they are adaptive immune systems against
invading plasmids or viruses
so protein or more or less they form a
ruin nuclean complex with the RNA which
is here in light blue and we have the
protein here so they form first of all
the complex
this complex can find my uh the by a
base carrying to DNA with the RNA and
then we have here the target sequence
and this spacer or Target sequence can
program to Target specific DNA sequences
via this crispr or CRNA or this or a
grna guide RNA
and therefore it's a powerful tool for
genome editing
so in nature there are a lot of Crystal
systems and they are very diverse I just
picked here three more or less the most
famous ones so first of all we have the
cas9 here and the custom a which are as
you see here monomeric so the protein
complex itself is monomeric and of
course they then form a bigger complex
but it's more or less monomeric
and we can have also live before Cascade
which is a multimeric protein has
multimeric domain structure here
and also for nucleus activity it has to
improve another protein that has three
and as we see here that the complex the
Stoichiometry is diverging and for
further research we picked then the cast
12 Family itself to look at it first of
all a bit more in detail
so therefore we looked or as you see
here already we have a very diverse
family from I just picture this five uh
one so that you have also we have from a
to e and so on the this there's also BC
and so on and so on like so it's a big
family you see also they are very
diverse in their size of the protein of
the RNA what they are targeting but what
is what I all have in common is that
they have a one-to-one
documentary if you look at the protein
RNA ratio
and and you look a bit more uh into
genome editing you have a need for small
proteins because they can
easier or more easily uh transported
into the nucleus
and so in that sense here when you look
at customer F you have it's the smallest
representative
within this family
um but the Stoichiometry is still
unknown or was still there known at that
time and we then used Miss photometry in
that sense as a fast method to obtain
this composition
for the for those of you who
just heard of of mass photometry and I
will quickly explain
how it works so we have incident light
which gets there into which is shy into
the sample or onto the sample here and
then we have reflect the light from the
bare glass surface and we have scattered
light from the biomolecules and this
reflected and Scattered light then
interfere with each other and this
interference pattern is then
proportional to the size of the
biomolecule
and there's one more thing you have to
to do before calibrating the system
um
no you have to calibrate the system
before you really get to measure the
whole thing
so what you normally measure is you
cannot measure molecular masses of
course you measure a ratio metric
contrast this ratiometric contrast
uh decreases linearly with increasing
Mass
and in that sense here we used a
multiple Rising protein
um as a calibration standard
and then we can use a very simple linear
fit to obtain the from the ratio metric
contrast the molecular masses
what we should have or what we should
keep in mind for the rest of the talk
already is that nucleic acids have a
slightly lower
molecular mass
calibration is done with the protein
standard
so this means for example for DNA
it appears only in in such a
spectrum with only about 80 percent of
the expected or calculated Mass
um you you would you you calculate it
so what uh have we done before we
actually get to the customer f
uh systems we use a
known complex or system here from Custom
a from at city but silos so for oxidants
and so we have here a big size protein
one over one thousand amino acids it has
a calculate or expect amounts of 151
kilo Dalton and when we measured the
protein alone we get an HP around 150
kilo dozen
it has a very small crispr RNA in
comparison to the protein size and of
course the Stoichiometry was known from
crazy and data so you see here that the
RNA is buried inside this very large
protein complex or protein itself
and um so when we then mixed the protein
with the crispr RNA we had a expected
mass of 166 kilowatt and we measured 167
kilo Dalton
which gave us nicely this uh the group
uh this one to one ratio which we were
expecting as well
and then we thought okay we go further
with this
and we look at the mass binary of the
binary complex of customer at one from
Central fermona's parametartica
and there we measured also the protein
itself with the expected mass of 57
kilodols and we got a measured mass of
59 kilowatt in which was and we expected
or in the
um yeah in the range of the whole system
and um so everything was fine
but when we measured then the binary
complex we expected as before a
one-to-one ratio so we were expecting
something around 125 kilowatts as a main
Peak
but we got always a main keep around 180
kilowatts so
what we could see is that since we
cannot explain the Stoichiometry by a
very simple one-to-one ratio
and so we then went
one step further we thought okay we have
to measure the RNA Mass directly
in that sense there was the next big
yeah
a big big big step in that sense uh so
we measured the RNA alone and we got
this
so why do we get such a not nicely
shaped Spectra Spectrum
[Music]
um yeah so the net as you know
um the glass surface is negatively
charged and therefore the protein
absorption
is is preferred and if we use then
nucleic acids we get only a low number
of events
foreign
so we therefore have to positively
charge the surface
then nucleic absorb acid absorption
becomes uh
or is then preferred
and we get a high number of events
and as you see here it's this this and
this are two spectrums of the same
RNA
but
here we
barely got any counts and here we have a
lot of counts just from the y-axis
already and we see here that we have a
mass of 62 kilo Dots and a expected mass
of a 68 kilod and so here again we see
that nucleic acids
um have a slightly
lower or shoulder lower or appeal with a
lower Mass than expected
um but also RNA and DNA uh differ a bit
from each other
with this knowledge we then went again
to assemble the puzzle in that sense so
we had the measurement of the protein
itself we then had the measurement of
the RNA and we could dive into the
effector complex again with all our
informations and that time we assumed a
two to one ratio for the from protein to
RNA and we got this
a few one or two months before we could
or when we were still in this process
there was a publication also on this
stoichiometries or on the structure of
these contexts and they could show as
well uh that we have two proteins here
and one RNA in that sense so we could
nicely get the same information with
Mass photometry
and we went in one step further
we took our binary complex and mixed it
with DNA to look if this binary complex
this two to one ratio in that sense is
also the active form
of
[Music]
which is then targeting DNA so we took a
big p or a piece of DNA with 250 kilo
delts in
this is calculated we measured it
um on a positively charged surface and
we got 205 kilodolts and
measured
and when we took and then we mixed this
all together we expected a peak around
390 kilo Dalton and what we see here is
a peak at 390 kilo Dalton for a two to
one to one ratio for the ternary complex
um
consisting of protein RNA and DNA
which was also
show or just recent published in that
sense in the same publication where they
also showed the complete the ternary
structure of the structure of the
ternary complex
and this was all done for central for
Monas per metatica in that sense we
had more
and so we played the same game
for the custom F1 complex of silver
silos so for oxidants
and I will not go too much into detail
with the numbers this time but we again
measured the protein itself the RNA
itself and we nicely got again the for
the binary complex the two to one ratio
in that sense and we went further on
again looking if the binary complex is
also targeting DNA in that sense and for
one one node node again we have from the
calculated mass and the appeared Mass so
again about 20 less
[Music]
and when we look at the ternary complex
we again expected a two to one to one
ratio in that sense and here we got
again a a peak around this position and
again A2 so we could resolve this two to
one to one ratio with Mass photometry
we had one last binary complex
um investigated uh from this time from
an uncultural short akion
and there again we measured the protein
itself with the RNA and we could resolve
again this binary complex with a two to
one ratio and
in that sense it's it was very nice and
then in the end if you have all the
information how you can measure this it
was very easy and quickly done
um a last example of how to
get into the composition of such
um complexes but this time with a
different
with a slightly different
um
uh situation
we got from our collaborators from
billions this transposes B which has a
mass of 46 kilodon
and
the problem was that it assembles with
the RNA during gene expression so there
was no
information on about how big the complex
itself was
we had a expected
um or calculated mass of the protein
itself but we want but our collaborators
wanted also to know what is the
the complex composition
and so a RNA measurement was not
possible and also of course there was no
there was no possibility to measure the
protein itself
and all our collaborators
uh lessons later you can measure uh read
this also in their publication in nature
so what I did then to to really get into
the
um to reveal this
um
composition
I look at the desorption events
so what I focused so far in this whole
talk was about the adsorption events
which
appear with a
positive or with a normal mass as you
know it the desorption events due to
mathematical uh correctness or however
you want to call this it's just
something mathematical that there is
their negative sign so
we can here we see what is going away
from the surface
and in that sense
since we use a normal glass surface and
not a
coated surface
we can look what is going away from the
surface as well as what is landing on
the surface and normally what is going
away from the surface if you have such a
mixture are the nucleic acids not the
the protein stays there
so we can obtain even more or in one
measurement you can obtain the
information of the nucleic acid
more or less without
uh that without having to measure the
nucleic acid itself
and in that sense I looked at this
negative or this desorption events and
we could then resolve this because we
see here okay they appear with
um 42 kilo Dalton
and um and when we then take into
account that they normally have a
slightly
um lower
Mass than calculated
we go into something perhaps
50 or 49 kilodon
and then this whole thing here revealed
a one-to-one ratio
so to summarize my talk
um you have to keep some things in mind
if you want to resolve such uh contexts
with DNA RNA and
and protein of course with such ternary
or binary complexes whatsoever
when you calibrate and use protein think
about
think or at any time or however you want
to however you calibrate the whole
system that only that they appear with
slightly different masses so a nice case
here DNA appears with about 80 of the
calculated mass and pro and RNA with
about 95 of the expected or calculated
Mass
to really measure nuclear assets and to
increase the event number and the
resolution
you should cope your surface with
polylizine before a measurement
and then you can yeah such
stoichiometries can be resolved
of binary and ternary complexes
and you can also you you can you do it
like this or as I showed you one slide
before with these auction events as well
but this you can ask me again later on
okay
and I have to say or more or less that
mesotometry in that sense is a very fast
method to unravel such protein DNA RNA
interactions and with that I'd like to
thank you for your attention and I would
like to thank refined for the
opportunity to speak to you and to give
this webinar in that sense
and furthermore I would like to thank
our collaborators from Bill news
and of course my group the molecular
biophysics group in Leipzig of Ralph's
Idol
um for the opportunity and the
discussions about this whole topic here
and yeah
I am done and please don't hesitate to
ask any questions thank you
thank you so informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar and if you have a question
that you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
how did you ensure that the binary
complex composition is not the opposite
such as two RNA molecules and one
protein
um yeah how do we do that so to do this
we employed measurements using more so
titrations in that sense so we um
I or I titrated then RNA
um more RNA instead of more protein and
in that sense I saw the same
composition or the same the complexes
itself look the same in the the Spectra
they look the same as if I titrated more
and more protein so in that sense we saw
that um
that the the complex
was the same and on the other side when
looking at the desorption events we saw
with more RNA we saw that we got a lot
more
[Music]
yeah these are dissolving uh molecules
uh then
using
um
the
uh with the protein we didn't see any
dissolving events so in that sense we we
solved this by titrating
um
the
protein with a more RNA
more questions
so our second question is
um how can unbinding events be used to
obtain masses of DNA or RNA
um
[Music]
uh yeah so I see I think in that sense
it's
um yeah so I will go to this slide one
more time
um sorry yeah
um
okay
so
um in that sense
to obtain the uh I have to look at the
question one more time
uh how can I mining events
I am so in so I mean it's it's very
simple in that sense this uh uh what you
see here which is in circled in red
um so these unbinding events if you have
a non-coded surface and
um
use then a mixture with protein and
nucleic acids you will always get these
um
this this High counts of of desorbing
events and here you can use
um this I mean it's negative but this is
just something mathematical it's nothing
real this negative thing so in that
sense uh yeah this can be used to to
obtain these negative all the masses not
negative masses but the masses of
nucleic acid in the sense of and then to
obtain
uh the composition as well
alrighty we have another question that
asks the negative values in this case of
the r
a tnpb complex would imply that the RNA
is falling out of the complex
um
I think
yes
um this we didn't uh was we went not too
far into this detail I
uh in that sense I just got the the the
samples from from our collaborators from
billions and
um yeah I think I mean normally
um there will always be some equilibrium
having
of course
[Music]
protein and and and RNA or nucleic acid
uh just by themselves and and as a
complex and I think in that sense
you really just see
um
yeah the desorbing of of uh in that
sense since you you I mean the the
protein complex with the RNA then is can
be seen as some kind of uh coating and
then we see that the
and that's in that sense some some of
the RNA can bind to the to to this site
and then these orbs again and I think so
in that sense we see just three nucleic
acids and and I think I don't think that
there is some kind of uh decomposition
of the of the tnbp complex in that sense
so it's more like
yeah it's it's it's like you see the
free the free RNA which is not in a in a
complex just
uh binding and desorbing again and in
that sense it's also very small so
you will not see it um or or I mean it's
it's just like I I told you before in
the
um
in the talk that they are not binding
right very well to the surface and so
these
these orbing is more obscene than than
the the real binding so I I think I I
talked a bit too much about this but I
hope that uh I I could give you an
answer for this
wonderful and then uh we have another
question that asks for my understanding
mass photometry is measuring the size of
the particle and then using the density
of the particle to calculate the mass
can this method use uh can this method
use to measure the size only can we use
it to measure other nanoparticles like
lipid or polyplex
um
I have to read the question one more
time
[Music]
um
what I can say is that we tried also in
our group to measure DNA origami
um
molecules and
to measure it
this
didn't work so well
um but I'm not 100 sure if they got it
to work but because I'm I'm in my in my
group I'm on the on the protein
DNA or in the crispr field so this I
cannot tell you
um that to measure the size
yeah you can measure the sizes only of
course I mean in that sense but for
other nanoparticles I think
this you should ask the team of refined
um they are more into this
[Music]
yeah all right
wonderful we have another question
could you explain again how you reach
the conclusion that the ratio is one to
one
um yeah of course I am I think this is
again regarding this tnpb so
um so the conclusion or how did I get to
this conclusion so I measured first uh
or I measured the complex
which was assembled already and I had
this was the only information I got and
then I measured the 96 kilo Dalton
and
The Next Step then was to look at the
desorption events which are here
encircled in red
and from that and then this is the this
is then the clear size of the RNA in
this solution or in this complex
because this is protein doesn't there
there would be only I don't know a few
one up to I don't know five to ten
um
events but not I I think this was like a
few hundred like 700 800 events or
something so you would clearly see a
difference if this was only protein or
um
or something which is not only protein
and um in that sense so this is clearly
the nucleic acid in that in this case
here RNA and if you then compare the
size of the RNA to the size of the
complex
um and we knew that the the mass of the
tnpb was 46 kilodalton
we could or we assumed from that uh that
the whole
um all that the ratio of this complex uh
is one to one
I hope
this is um
now answered
yes and then we have another question
that says
um why can you not see dissorbing of the
whole complex at once
um
I mean you see sorry you see some I will
just go perhaps previously yeah
so now it's not Instagram I mean you see
here at the 100 also and and a bit lower
so at the negative side
um you see also some events what I
Told You So Far So these there are some
minor uh deserving events of course of
the whole
um complex itself
um I think but I'm not 100 sure uh a
colleague of mine uh she also did
measurements with a coated
um
surface
um a measuring protein in DNA complexes
and
I think there she could see some or more
dissolving events of such a
um protein DNA complex
but for me this was not not this was not
the the question in this experiment but
you you will or you you would see
um the the complex itself if you would
use a um coated slide with a polylizene
in that sense
oh really and then for grna can we use
nucleic acid calibrants instead of
protein calibrants well this year old
more accurate Mass values
yes of yes this if you if you if you're
just interested in measuring grna and
not in measuring complex or complexes
with different composition then you can
always use
um
a calibrant
so just like a nucleic acid or if you
even have it you could just use
um a RNA as for your calibration this
would be even more accurate so it was
for me it was uh I had to decide or to
to say like I've I have to calibrate
with one of those three in that sense
and I was then saying okay I use protein
um and measure everything then one time
um as a only measurement
to obtain these muscles and to know okay
what what is the difference between the
real value and and the measured value
and so I got this inaccuracies in that
sense but yeah you this it's it's up to
you what you use for for protein or 404
calibration
alrighty and it looks like we have time
for one more question and it is is the
surface modification with Paul
polylizing easy to carry out
yes
um the the surface modification I think
it takes like
roughly one minute or something it's
it's not it's done very easily so you
have your prepared I think it was one or
ten percent poly license
um solution
um but this is this is uh this is always
uh according up to a protocol from
refined so
um it's just you add a drop off on on
one of your slides and then you just put
two slides together like like a cross
um and then you have in the middle
you're you're polarizing and then you
just uh dry it and then just um
dip it into water one time to to wash
out excessive or excess um
polylizing and then that's it so it's
it's very easily very convenient and
um yeah so in that sense it's it's good
it's good and easy
thank you Sagar do you have any final
comments for our audience
um yeah use use mesotometry in that
sense I'm in the beginning I was also a
bit
um yeah okay how how this is all working
but it's it's easy it's um and what I
really like is that you don't need any
labels like fluorescent labels or spin
labels or whatsoever and you can easily
get the purify purity of your Solutions
and
um
equilibria and how does it really look
in in your solution uh sometimes you
don't know it and this was also for me
the the information were very very
important for my single molecule
experiments which I employed uh up on
the information I obtained by a mass
photometry
wonderful thank you again Zagar for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor refine for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye